on pense tous confond serait dans le
bâtiment en flammes
mais tant qu'on ne sent pas la brûlure
on ne peut pas savoir
vous savez vous avez préféré mourir
plutôt que d'abandonner vos collègues
[Musique]
cette épreuve que vous avez réussi
elle n'est pas donné à tout le monde
bienvenue dans l'au delà
pour faire mon travail il faut que j'ai
une idée de ce qui nous menace
d'après ce que j'ai compris
nous essayons d'éviter la troisième
guerre mondiale
le low cost nucléaire
non
pire que ça
je n'ai qu'un mot à vous donner pénet
vous ouvrira les bonnes portes
et parfois aussi les mauvaises
vous devez vous mettre à voir le monde
différemment
n'essayez pas de le comprendre
[Musique]
ressentez le
s'est passé quoi ici ça s'est pas encore
passé